[Musique]
si jamais j'étais là faut pas m'en
vouloir
ce matin c'est l'énergie du jade c'est
pas la première fois que je viens
[Applaudissements]
et à chaque fois je dis bien jouissant
bien on croit souvent que je suis plus
guide et quand on dit ah tu es plus
jeune femme
que j'adore cette ville si je suis
originaire
je suis vraiment ravi d'être parmi vous
aujourd'hui parce que d'abord ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas eu le bonheur les
plaisirs d'être face à des étudiants
comme vous à cause du covid et je suis
fait un devoir ça c'est quelque chose
que mon père nous a enseigné c'est
toujours transmettre on a fait au
sérieux et c'est un devoir remercier ce
matin notamment l'équipe encadrante et
les enseignants de ce merveilleux
établissements me remercier d'être là il
faut pas me remercier c'est vraiment un
peu voir que de transmettre le peu de
choses que l'on sait parce que d'autres
aussi et on n'est pas du tout les
propriétaires et ça je vous dis avec
toute la modestie du monde
vous allez recevoir au cours de votre
parcours ne vous appartient pas de la
même manière que tout ce que j'ai pu
recevoir au cours de mon parcours de
n'appartient pas nous en sommes les
dépositaires et en tant que dépositaire
nous avons le devoir tout son temps que
nous sommes de prendre ce qu'on nous a
donné de partager ce que vous avez
[Applaudissements]
parce que
[Musique]
ce que vous partagez
ne vous appauvrez pas ce que vous donnez
comme savoir comme connaissance comme
conseil comme idée ne vous appauvrez pas
cela vous enrichit au contraire parce
que vous gardez ce savoir vous gardez
cette connaissance vous perdez cette
expertise et vous permettez à quelqu'un
d'autre d'en faire peut-être des choses
encore
que vous n'avez fait jusqu'à présent et
des choses peut-être qui vous
reviendront ensuite dans le futur et qui
vous rendront encore plus riche en tant
qu'être humain et ça c'est vraiment
vital s'il y a une chose à retenir s'il
vous plaît c'est de partager et ça c'est
vraiment fondamental et essentiel
ça a été cité je vous remercie de la
présentation qui a été faite en
introduction
effectivement je vais commencer par la
fin je vous ai donné une première chose
à retenir la seconde c'est celle-ci
rien n'est impossible et je vous le dis
avec
la chair de poule parce que c'est
quelque chose que j'ai éprouvé et bien
évidemment je ne suis pas le seul et je
rajoute à cette formule l'impossible
n'est rien je vous jure et je vous le
dis avec toute la sincérité qui s'impose
dans un contexte comme celui-ci
si vous voulez réaliser quelque chose
si vous avez un objectif
vous allez y arriver personne et rien ne
peut vous en empêcher soyez convaincus
de cela
combien de fois on a dit c'est
impossible c'est impossible
qu'un être humain passe en dessous des
10 secondes sur le 100 mètres allez dire
ça à Usain Bolt 9 secondes 58
c'est impossible
de courir le marathon en moins de deux
heures allez dire ça à Eliot de
kitchoguer une heure 59
c'est impossible
d'envoyer
un robot sur Mars et de faire voler un
drone sur une planète qui est si
lointaine
avec une atmosphère inexistante à dire
ça et il a été cité tout à l'heure par
mon imperdouane à Kamel oudril et par la
mine
c'est impossible pour une Marocaine de
gravir l'Everest
et les six autres sommets les plus
élevés allez dire ça à bouche à la baby
donc vous rencontrerez
des gens au cours de votre parcours qui
vont dire
c'est impossible
et vous aurez alors la responsabilité
comme l'ont fait ces personnalités que
j'ai cité dont vous l'aurez remarqué de
Marocains et marocains donc ça veut dire
que on n'est pas exclu on n'est pas
privé nous aussi de faire des choses
extraordinaires chacun a son niveau
et bien lorsqu'on vous dira que c'est
impossible pensez à ces exemples là
et mettez-vous à la place à la place de
la femme
ou de l'homme
d'où cela qui va montrer que c'est
possible et que cette personne avec toi
de
gens bon vous dire
c'est pas fait pour toi c'est simple
alors il y a deux catégories
il y a la première catégorie qui n'est
pas néfaste et qui va vous dire c'est
trop compliqué c'est impossible c'est
pas pour vous chiffon Léo
cette catégorie là ce sont des personnes
qui lorsque vous leur présentez votre
projet votre ambition
[Musique]
à bord cette ambition à travers leurs
propres limites
et sans méchanceté
puisque à leurs yeux ce n'est pas
faisable pour vous également ce n'est
pas faisable
vous imaginez si c'était vrai le gamin
que j'étais
je suis l'acide d'un petit pack même
dans le sud de la France qui s'appelle
Pierre latte
dans la Drôme originaire d'un petit
patelin dans le centre du Maroc qui
s'appelle la côte de solo
et à 8 ans 7 ans 9 ans pendant toute mon
adolescence
je disais à des gens que je rencontrais
d'un certain âge ou même des camarades
voilà un jour je serai présentateur du
journal télévisé
ça aurait pu être tout autre chose
[Musique]
et tous les métiers quels qu'ils soient
et j'insiste mon papa était artisan
maçon et c'est un excellent artisan à
son tous les métiers quels qu'ils soient
se respectent à partir du moment où vous
les respecter et vous vous respectez
[Applaudissements]
et donc j'en ai rencontré des gens qui
m'ont dit c'est impossible
[Musique]
et puis il y a l'autre qui va vous dire
c'est impossible
et qui sait que vous avez les capacités
de faire
et qui sait que vous pouvez y arriver et
que lui ou elle ne peut pas y arriver ce
cette catégorie là est un peu plus
sournoise un peu plus dangereux
mais vous n'avez pas d'énergie à perdre
avec ces gens-là donc la solution
c'était laisser de côté
éloignez-vous des gens qui ont des
problèmes pour chaque solution comme
disait il me semble Albert Einstein
éloigné vous devez
pas grave ils essaient de vous casser
ils essaient de vous mettre des bâtons
dans les roues
laissez-les enfermer dans leur cycle
néfaste et négatif
et vous continuez d'avancer
continuer de tendre
vers cette ambition et ce rêve que vous
nourrissez
j'ai lâché le premier mot de ma formule
parce que quand je disais ton gamin que
je voulais être présentateur du journal
télévisé
parmi les remarques que l'on faisait ou
des réponses que l'on faisait on dit
belle
et je réponds
[Musique]
et avec le recul avec l'âge avec les
cheveux blancs on se pose des questions
on fait une introspection je me suis dit
d'où ça vient ce truc là pourquoi est-ce
que un moment alors que mes parents ma
mère vont être collaborée mon père
de grandes études ou pas études du tout
qui nous ont pas spécialement orientés
pourquoi il y a un truc qui fait qu'à un
moment il y a un rendez-vous avec le
destin comme ça a été souligné par mes
chers prédécesseurs
et j'ai essayé ça c'est mon parcours
j'ai fait spécialités
scientifique et juste pour dire que j'ai
un patientifique après je suis orienté
vers le droit et c'est résidus qui
menacé des mathématiques et de de
l'enfer des fonctions et des équations
j'ai sorti de cela avec le recul une
équation
qui s'appelle
sortez vos copies doubles stylo rouge s
=
RP puissance 3 s
= RP puissance 3 c'est la souverain la
preuve que j'étais pas excellente
maintenant je fais très simple
est-ce pour le succès finalement le
succès c'est l'ambition
[Musique]
de quoi le succès pour tout à chacun
pour un chanteur c'est de rencontrer son
public pour un journaliste c'est
d'exercer dans le média qu'il souhaite
réaliser pour un
représentant ou quelqu'un qui qui
ambitionne de faire ceci ou cela c'est
la teinte finalement l'objectif qui va
alors quels sont les composants de cette
recette
que j'ai concoctée et vous allez voir
j'ai rien inventé c'est des choses que
vous allez retrouver chez des personnes
qui sont arrivées
le premier élément c'est celui que je
vous ai cité c'est le r du rêve
si vous plaît tous autant que vous êtes
permettez-vous de rêver
aujourd'hui on est tellement assailli
par les images par les sons par les
sources par les soucis par les ceux là
on en oublie l'essentiel
c'est de rêver
le rêve c'est ce qu'il y a de plus
puissant
ça vous éloigne de tout ça vous
rapproche de ce que vous désirez et ça
casse toutes
les vagues quand j'étais gamin il y a
personne qui pouvait m'empêcher de rêver
de Me rêver présentateur
et là je me posais derrière mon bureau
ma table en cours et je me réveille
madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue dans
cette édition voici les titres de
l'actualité et je divaguais comme ça
et c'est ce rêve que vous allez réaliser
le fait d'identifier
le chemin vers lequel vous voulez vous
orienter qui va générer
le déclic de l'énergie qui va vous
permettre de continuer à avancer et de
surmonter les obstacles qui dans le réel
vont se présenter à vous
tout le monde peut rêver
c'est gratuit on aurait tort de s'en
priver
et ma grande chance comme beaucoup
d'ailleurs d'autres personnes c'est
d'avoir rêvé très jeune
l'un d'ouvre
[Musique]
cet objectif là je sais pas pourquoi
j'ai choisi ce métier je sais un peu ce
que je regardais à la télévision et je
me suis dit tiens pas mal comme métier
et derrière son bureau dans un studio et
puis présenter et puis recevoir des
invités etc etc ça aurait pu être ni
l'autre chose mais je me suis agrippé à
ce rêve comme on s'agrippe à la vie
le deuxième élément de la recette et de
la formule est-ce = RP puissance 3 le
premier T et ça a été cité par nos amis
c'est celui de la passion
la passion mesdames messieurs c'est le
véritable
réacteur
de votre
usine humaine de la machine c'est le
cœur du réacteur
c'est parce que vous êtes passionné
que vous allez pouvoir
continuer à avancer à nourrir l'énergie
qui a été suscité par le rêve que vous
nous lisez
il faut être passionné soyez des êtres
passionnés moi mon métier vous savez ça
fait plus de 20 ans que je le pratique
je l'adore je suis fou amoureux de mon
[Musique]
et j'ai l'habitude de dire l'essentiel
pour vous c'est de faire ce que vous
aimez faites ce que vous aimez peut-être
que vous n'allez pas trouvé tout de
suite mais cherchez un peu c'est comme
l'âme sœur elle ne vous attend pas au
détour d'une rue et des rencontres qui
se font il y a des belles surprises et
puis quand bien même
si vous rencontrez un domaine ne le
rejetez pas tout de suite
combien de personnes sont passées à côté
de l'amour de leur vie parce qu'ils
n'ont pas pris le temps d'échanger avec
elle ou avec lui
alors même si vous ne trouvez pas ce que
vous aimez
apprenez à aimer ce que vous êtes
susceptible de faire et peut-être que la
flamme à ce moment-là va se déclencher
soyez curieux allez regardez explorer
combien d'entre nous et ça a été dit sur
cette scène sont finalement tombés
amoureux de ce qu'il faisait alors qu'il
l'ignorait
[Musique]
donc aller au devant soyez curieux
explorer ça il y a une conférence à
Paris qui se prépare
j'écoute la publicité à la radio qui est
consacrée au métier de demain grosso
modo pour la faire court et Monsieur
Léopold c'est beaucoup mieux que moi à
8h la moitié des métiers qui existeront
dans 10 ans et qui existent pas encore
aujourd'hui pour la faire courte c'est
dire ce que ça vous demande à vous en
faire d'exploration
et mais ce que vous faites la vérité il
y a rien à moi vous savez
raconter une petite anecdote par rapport
à deux heures encore aujourd'hui ça fait
16 ans que je suis à 2 ans
quasiment jour pour jour
[Musique]
et encore aujourd'hui
quand je prépare le journal du soir je
viens j'arrive à la chaîne de mes
collègues peuvent en témoigner à 8h voir
à 9h j'arrive à 9h du matin pour un truc
qui passe à 20h15 donc ça veut dire
facile 11 heures 12 heures de présence
sans parler du travail qui a été fait en
amont
[Musique]
je peux pas me permettre de proposer un
journal qui ne soit pas à la hauteur de
l'amour que je porte à ce métier et à la
hauteur de l'amour et de la
considération que le public me porte je
ne pourrais pas regarder dans la glace
tout simplement c'est l'amour de mon
métier qui me fait dépenser toute cette
énergie
la passion le rêve la passion le
deuxième fait de la formule c'est la
persévérance
ça il y a pas de secret il n'y a
personne et ça a été dit personne
aucune personne qui a réussi ne vous
dira j'ai réussi du premier coup
vous allez ça a été du paramètres ça
fait du pardon ça dédié par Monsieur
Léopold tout à l'heure vous allez tomber
et vous allez vous relever vous savez
combien de fois j'ai tenté les concours
d'école de journaliste
j'ai fait un dog endroit deux endroits
que j'ai passé les concours premier
passage échec voilà je fais un licence
de droit en attendant de passer du bon
fonds tu passes les concours deuxième
échec je fais une maîtrise de droit
j'obtiens mon amétrie sans problème je
passe les concours troisième échec je
fais un DEA un diplôme d'études
approfondie en droit international des
droits de l'homme à Montpellier je finis
major de promo
et on me dit à Montpellier a tué major
de promo tu es en fait on était c'était
sur dossier on était 29 ou 30
voilà tu vas voir une course tu vas être
tu vas enseigner à la fac parce que les
Guinée c'était mon chargeur on directeur
de mémoire je me suis les vider moi vous
savez ce qui me passionne c'est le
journalisme et je l'ai fait du droit que
pour atteindre le concours donc je vous
laisse tout la Bourse
le poste de professeur vacataire
assistant machin tout ce que vous voulez
moi je vais aller tenter ma chance et je
passe pour la quatrième fois deux écoles
finalement je les options les deux
[Applaudissements]
et je vous passe toutes les fois où je
me suis cassé la gueule ou je me suis
relevé ou j'ai douté etc prendre un
exemple
merci
il y a peut-être un décalage avec la
distance
[Musique]
chaque main
Jackman multimilliardaire chinois celui
qui a lancé unibaba
comme s'il allait présenter son projet
regardez les documents c'est hyper hyper
hyper intéressant à l'époque début des
années 90 en Chine la Chine ce n'est pas
ce que ce que c'est devenu aujourd'hui
début des années 90 le mec qui va dans
les administrations chinoises il va leur
parler de sites internet déjà en France
aux États-Unis par les sites Internet
des années 90 fallait être un taré comme
Steve Jobs Bill Gates d'accord Jackman
en Chine Jackman a gagné 20 dollars par
mois comme professeur d'anglais et où
est-ce qu'il a appris l'anglais c'est
pas à l'école c'est en accompagnant les
touristes et en les écoutant parler à
côté de lui ça c'est que la persévérance
hop à ces quatre fois le cours d'école
du journalisme à la rigueur c'est pareil
ça
donc persévérer tenez bon tenez bon ne
lâchez rien ne lâchez rien
le troisième est de la formule c'est la
projection
alors ça ça demande un peu plus de temps
il reste deux minutes ça suffira
projeter
parce que le fait de vous projeter vous
émettez dans l'univers des pensées et
ces pensées ça a été matérialisée par
les scientifiques ce sont des ondes
et ces ondes elles vont se propager dans
l'univers et elles vont vibrer avec
certaines fréquence je vous jure que ça
marche on pourra je pourrais faire une
autre conférence pour vous expliquer les
donner des exemples un peu plus
détaillés mais je vous jure que ça
marche croyez-moi sur parole
et elles vont aller vivre en vibrant la
même fréquence elles vont aller
rencontrer d'autres situations qui
vivent ou d'autres personnes qui vivent
à la maltraitance monsieur Léopold
parlait tout à l'heure de ses papas de
ses personnes qui l'ont accompagné ce
sont les bonnes ordres le café qui a
pris tout à l'heure c'est
c'était les ondes qui les mettaient
parce qu'il voulait être dans un univers
professionnel plus à l'aise et plus
enrichissant pour lui et c'est pour ça
qu'il y a ce qui a fait qui lui ouvre de
grosses opportunités ça s'appelle de la
projection
combien de fois ça vous arrive vous
cherchez que parking
et les choses se mettent en place pour
que vous puissiez trouver et ça c'est un
travail c'est une rigueur à laquelle il
faut s'atteler systématiquement
s = RP puissance 3 le rêve la passion la
persévérance
et la projection et d'ailleurs vous
savez moi quand je suis arrivé
à 2m
je suis arrivé pour un stage de 4 mois
comme par hasard au moment où j'arrive
en ayant loupé 4 fois et heureusement
que j'ai loupé 4 fois les concours au
moment où j'arrive il y a eu des
présentatrices qui s'en va comme par
hasard je demande à faire des essais
comme par hasard mes essais arrivent sur
le bureau de la directrice de l'info
comme par hasard elle nous demande de
passer les castings et comme par hasard
parmi trois personnes dont deux anciens
de la chaîne c'est moi à 25 ans sans
aucune expérience et avec une jolie
bagage qui suit retenue
pendant des années voire des dizaines
d'années
de mots pour conclure
la formule elle est double s = RP
puissance 3 le P puissance 3 ça veut
aussi dire prise de parole en public les
amis vous aurez beau avoir les plus
belles idées du monde si vous n'êtes pas
en mesure de vous
défendre et ne vous vendre par exemple
dans une conférence comme celle que vous
organisez
c'est du gâchis
c'est du gâchis prise de parole en
public on a tous des obstacles on a tous
les difficultés je suis intimide maladif
si on m'avait dit à l'âge de 8 ans que
je suis capable de parler de vendre des
dizaines des centaines voire des
milliers de personnes comme s'aimer
arriver ah ouais moi je peux faire ça
ouais
vous pouvez tous non seulement vous
pouvez tous mais vous devez tous
et je terminerai par
cette phrase
jamais peur de voir grand
d'accord
n'ayez jamais peur de voir grand vous y
allez pas à pas thank big start small
OK
toujours parler de Kamel ou dans les
tout à l'heure et de la NASA toujours
toujours toujours toujours toujours
des étoiles et qui a le bon étoile
si vous voulez là parce que même en cas
d'échec c'est pas grave
vous finirez par atterrir sur la lune je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]